Hey, this is Presh Talwalkar.
I found this neat puzzle on the Internet.
Imagine a rectangular grid of circles.
We'll color in some of the circles with blue dots to make a mathematical equation.
It currently reads (71 + 1)(71 − 1) = 71.
But this is not a correct equation.
The puzzle is to either color one blue dot,
or erase one blue dot to make a valid equation.
Can you figure it out?
Give this problem a try and when you're ready keep watching the video for a solution.
So, how can we make this a valid equation?
The surprising answer is that in the very last digit of 1,
erase the second blue dot from the bottom.
The left-hand side of this equation
evaluates to (71 + 1)(71 - 1) = 72 × 70 = 5040.
The right hand side evaluates to 7 factorial.
The one becomes an exclamation point which is a factorial,
so we take the product of 1 to 7, and we get 5040.
And that's how we get a valid equation.
Did you figure it out?
Thanks for watching this video.
I post math videos that can be watched for free with topics from people around the world because math is universal.
If you'd like to help the cause, please subscribe for free to get the newest videos,
watch and share all of Mind Your Decisions videos,
and email me a puzzle or math topic at presh@mindyourdecisions.com.
If you liked this video, you can check out my books which are linked in the video description,
And if you so choose you can support this cause financially on Patreon to earn exclusive rewards
Thanks for watching and thanks for your support.